93 we go public
we go from where we can't hardly get
three million dollar loan from um
uh national city bank in kentucky yeah
we'll kentucky three million dollars
what was your uber when you went public
do you remember like
thirty
it was a good evening okay good yeah to
where the company's worth 200 million
dollars i think it was june uh june 26
and 93. we go from where i didn't have
five grand to go on vacation with the
family to now i'm worth 100 million
bucks one day
but i still felt broke
until
we really turned on the measurement
system and the new culture
in o304
i didn't we were successful we made a
lot of money we took the stock from 13 a
share
if you look at pre-spit pre-split
probably 130 bucks 10x it was yeah easy
maybe even more i don't know how many
times we split the stock so many times
um but i it was from the fear of failure
back to the 2000 store it was like i was
doing it because i was worried about
going broke so 20 years you're going
with this feeling what was the first
night you slept where you slept
so 84 you're doing this you're starting
it when did you really sleep because
there's a difference between sleeping
and sleeping
i think you know what i'm asking i think
99 2000 was 16 years where i really kind
of went okay i can
i can get a good night's i think that
yeah i mean i definitely slept better
okay
this is where i got to interject here
for a second
you're saying for 15 years you didn't
even sleep no not didn't sleep that's
not no i didn't i didn't say not sleep i
said sleep good he said this was the
first time that he really
gots a good night's sleep
this goes back to your point but you
know what it is to sleep with that level
of fear and paranoia and someone's
afternoon what if we go out of business
it's a different kind of this is what
i'm asking that's what i want to tap
into understand that nature and by the
way here's a crazy thing even after you
get the 100 200 300 million in the bank
right because you've been in that state
for so long you still don't know how to
snap out of that state
at least that's my experience yourself
16 years well the we measure the sleep
every night so i'll probably know more
about sleep today yeah
but um the war rings uh but i love it
if you read the book while we sleep yeah
all you can do is read the first page
the amount of things that happen when
you sleep are as far as repair
um i would i'd say i slept
but really not um in
when you when you're in a state of fear
you're in the reptilian part of the
brain
you know it's we call it a brain
regression flight or fight
and you know your your your repair to
your your body is done in the neural
corplex uh cortex the frontal lobe of
your body
and i think good night's sleep is more
about getting in the frontal lobe of
uh don't think that if you don't spend
the world the world ain't going to spin
um
a position of okay i'm in this for
everybody to win i'm in this for the
better event of humanity i'm in this to
better my community i'm in this because
we're proud of what we serve i mean
there's a
higher level of consciousness that come
when you operate from
a position of compassion thoughtfulness
then when you're operating because
you're afraid you're going to get broken
you're counting your money every day so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]